uh with the late night sets I think the
one that uh caught your eye Barry
quarter of course is the shack diesel
sets but I'm sure you are really excited
about I am very excited actually it's a
really good lineup
um we can go through it here real quick
yeah please do we knew My Morning Jacket
because we found that out months ago but
what else did uh what else did I miss
who else is gonna be there so Thursday
uh Zed's Dead liquid stranger 070 Shake
uh Big Freedia your your hello I love
Frida I love food that is gonna that is
gonna be a twerking uh explosion are you
ready Barry are you ready to twerk I
know I know you gotta get ready to hang
some Sheetrock
laughs I bet Big Frida can hang from
here I uh
my dad is the rest of that night I love
man I love diarrhea planet um that's
probably the the show I'm most excited
about on Thursday is diarrhea planet
that
um anyway but the thing about Frida is
that you know you can't walk six blocks
in New Orleans without seeing or hearing
some sort of Big Frida coming out of
somebody's house and and you know what's
happening in that house they're uh yeah
the bounce is on
um and then Friday what do we get Friday
Saturday Sunday Friday uh I'm gonna go
in kind of reverse order because I want
to mention something Boogie T dirt
monkey and sub doctor uh diesel which
you just mentioned our man Shaq I'm
really looking forward to that destroy
lonely the midnight our friend Sylvan
Esso and subtronics and wolf pack and I
I said them last because I just stumbled
across a YouTube video the other day
comparing
um weather report and their song teen
town to wolf packs Dean town I I didn't
know anything about wolf pack I know
weather report very well so it was kind
of curious to have stumbled across that
so you're not so you're not Hungry Like
the Wolf I will I'm gonna be yeah I'm
actually wrong
um all right and then Sunday or is that
Friday so Saturday got it okay Saturday
uh as you mentioned my favorite band My
Morning Jacket corn
Louis the child
and uh
so which one are you choosing are you
choosing My Morning Jacket or corn
because I am sure they're gonna be in
the exact same time slot I'm gonna do My
Morning Jacket it's what no I'm stunned
I could probably go see corn and the
other four and during the time that I'm
gonna guess my morning jacket's gonna be
on stage yeah look I yeah My Morning
Jacket show is going to be um pretty
fantastic they're gonna have a whole uh
thing around that show and the universe
not the anniversary but looking back at
their set from
um years ago in the rain I can't wait I
you know I I've said this a lot about My
Morning Jacket I don't necessarily think
that they are for me the easiest
sessionable uh band just put them on and
listen to it uh I've never really
experienced them that way
that I've Loved but man that live show
is something so special and so fun
um and big and it's gonna it's gonna it
is gonna be big it's gonna be yeah it's
gonna be a moment
um and it's gonna be this magical
bondering moments that I don't think
that you want to miss I agree 100 I can
listen to him uh you know while I'm
working around the house hanging
sheetrock but that's where I'm a little
different but I agree live it's
something completely different so what
about what about Taco is Taco doing corn
or My Morning Jacket
probably a little both little of a
column a little color B okay you are you
would be the guy I know that there's
somebody around the farm that has gone
to every show in the history of Bonnaroo
you know there at least there was like
seven ten years ago there was a guy that
was specifically trying to hit every
stage and try to go to Every band I
don't know if he's still around anymore
but that would be what Taco would want
to do he would want to go to Every if
you could do one year where you just go
five minutes at every single show I
think you could do it
sounds like the path to Madness yeah wow
yeah you can tick off all the bands
you've seen But then describe it yeah
what did you say no no clue what are you
going to get away with it was a run by
and then and then uh finish this up on
well there's nothing on Sunday there's
no late night on Sunday that's right